- Hello
- Is anybody home
- This is when I was much younger,
he asked me to get out
and stand on one leg,
cause he assumed something
that wasn't true.
I told him I couldn't do that because
of a football injury, and
I never played football,
so it was all I did, he
bought it, let me go.
- By a police officer?
- Melissa!
(mumbles)
- Oh I guess I'm guilty.
- In college we had these girls
that lived next door to us,
and we would do pranks on
them, we would hang smelt,
outside their door...
- Tell us what smelt is?
- [Melissa] What's smelt?
- [Chelsea] It's a small fish.
- Then we would take garbage cans,
It's like a big sardine.
So they got back at us by
sending us this beautiful
pan of brownies, but then
my other roommate ate
a whole row, and he was in
the bathroom for 10 days.
Because they had filled the
brownies with ex-lax. so we...
- You guys asked for it.
- That was their retribution.
- Garbage. That's for garbage people.
- That's for garbage people.
- People that would put ex-lax
in brownies would do that.
- That's right.
- What do you think this is?
We're good people, we're good people.
- Yeah I feel like I have.
- I have.
- I feel like I have.
- No doubt, No question.
- Now we're just trying
to be cool, like, yeah...
- [Joe] Yeah I feel like that.
I feel like I jumped a fence.
- [Joel] Now we're bad.
- Definitely did that.
- [Stephanie] I did.
- I feel like I probably
did that as a kid.
- [Dirk] I did as a kid.
- I don't remember, I
blotted out my childhood.
- [Joe] Guilty.
- [Melissa] Yeah.
- [Chelsea] Never.
- Well I did it once, and
that was enough for me.
- You haven't done it since?
- Fuck no.
- We had John Daily.
- [Chelsea] John Daily?
- [Melissa] Really?
- [Chelsea] He has piercing blue eyes.
- Well, These people were blind.
- Oh actually no, I did show
up to a photo shoot once,
there was a picture of another actress,
with my name under it.
- Oops.
- Does that just mean binge Netflix?
- No that's where you jay oh
while you're watching Netflix.
- Whooaaa.
I've been married too long for that.
- What's Instagram?
- That's why it said 'No
way' when we had it up there.
- Not an ex, nope.
- [Stephanie] Not an ex?
- [Melissa] Not an ex?
- [Joe] Not an ex.
- [Stephanie] Like, I'm married!
- Oh.
- [Voiceover] And we're done,
very awesome, thank you guys.
- [Chealsea] Thank you.
- [Stephanie] Thank you.
- [Joel] Thank you.
- [Melissa] Thank you.
- [Joe] Thank you.
- [Dirk] Thank you.